le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ces
annonces étaient attendues il était
temps d'ailleurs qu'elle ait lieu bien
entendu j'imagine qu'il aura d'autres
dans les jours à venir mais notre
commission de la culture au sénat qui
avait auditionné franck riester il ya
une douzaine de jours est en attente
d'un certain nombre de questions que
nous lui avions formulées quelle
anticipation qu'elle lisibilité pour le
secteur culturel quelle réponse apporter
à cette industrie
je parle d'industrie volontairement
c'est pas péjoratif au contraire c'est
très qualitatif ces ouï dire que le
secteur public est un secteur économique
extrêmement puissant c'est 3 2% du pib
c'est beaucoup plus d'emplois que dans
le secteur automobile
et c'est toute une série de métiers
qu'on ne connaît pas railler mais sur
les acteurs les artistes qui sont en
première ligne qui sont visibles mais
derrière tout ça ce sont des métiers des
techniciens des des éclairagistes d'où
ce monde qui accompagne la production
culturelle
donc il n'y avait pas vraiment de
réponse complète
même si un fonds d'urgence avait été
décrété et là on a un peu plus de
précisions notamment ce qui concerne la
question de l'intermittence oui est-ce
que vous jugez que cela arrive tout de
même tard même si bon il ya
effectivement cette annonce sur le
prolongement de droit des intermittents
jusqu'à ou 2021
disons que illégitime d'analyser la
situation et les sujets sont tellement
nombreux dans le cadre de la réponse à
apporter à la crise qu'on peut
comprendre qu'il fallait un peu de
réflexion
mais malgré tout il faut rassurer et
pouvoir dire aussi à tous ces artistes à
tous ces créateurs tous ces techniciens
et administratifs va qu'on pense aussi à
eux comme faisant partie prenante d'une
dynamique économique qui est porteuse
d'ailleurs de rayonnement et
d'attractivité pourquoi la france
est-elle un atout immense et je trouve
ça arrivait un peu en décalage par
rapport aux annonces ont fait toutes les
grandes régions qui ont d'emblée depuis
un certain temps voter leurs plans
d'urgence et même parfois de relance et
son anticipation et que du coup voilà on
était un petit recueil on verra bien
quel parent pauvre de ce plan pour vous
dans un premier temps dans un premier
temps oui d'ailleurs je dois dire que
les mesures qui ont été annoncées et
tant mieux nous les soutenons fortement
en faveur bien sûr de tout le secteur
économique en général et étaient les
bienvenus mais il fallait y penser
particulièrement à ce secteur qui a des
règles aussi un petit peu particulière
parce que la question de l'intermittence
est une réalité de l'emploi dans le
secteur culturel qui n'existe pas
ailleurs
les artistes sont pas employés d'une
seule structure les techniciens les et
clarisse ont paru de sa structure il
accumule une série de contrats voilà
tout au long d'une période dédiée qui
ouvre après le droit à l'assurance
chômage
or tout cela vole en éclats quand il
n'ya plus de création et de diffusion